So withdrawal effects are in the opposite direction of the effects that the
drug produces. Let's look at an example of heroin. So here, we will list the
effects that heroin produces. And we will see that when a person experiences
withdrawal, those effects are opposite. Let's start first with analgesia. So
heroin produces a variety of effects, we'll just look at four. One is
analgesia, this means it's a pain reliever. It will also produce pupil
constriction, meaning, people will have tiny pinpoint-like pupils. Also, it
produces euphoria. In fact, this is why people abuse heroin. And finally,
another effect is constipation. Now, a person who is physically dependent on
heroin and doesn't get the drug will now start to experience withdrawal
symptoms. And these are in the opposite direction, let's take a look. So the
withdrawal effects would be hyperalgesia, which is an increased sensitivity to
pain, pupil dilation, dysphoria,as well as diarrhea. In addition, people
undergoing withdrawal from heroin experience what they call a terrible flu-like
feeling. And these withdrawal symptoms can last for weeks. Therefore it is not
surprising when people go out to look for the drug to try to diminish those
withdrawal symptoms.